hey youtubers is Charlie so I just
learned some really awesome news about
the future of gorilla grodd on the flash
so I thought I'd do a video for it
before I go rewatch Star Wars for like
the billions time
just careful for spoilers from the flash
season 2 episode 7 if you haven't seen
it yet it's the grata sewed the
showrunner Andrew Kreisberg was talking
about the ending you know as well as the
other big CG creatures that they do and
what a surprise that they've been able
to do these big things like king shark
gorilla grodd even zoom a lot of zoom is
CG if he didn't realize it but behind
the scenes when they were originally
writing the episode they didn't have
gorilla City at the end just because it
was gonna cost so much money to do the
CG for the whole cityscape he made this
big joke about how they showed him this
picture of a sign that said gorilla City
and they're like well we couldn't do the
city so we put up a sign that said
gorilla City and the first joke out of
his mouth was like why is the sign in
English who is this sign for is it for
hikers that are just mysteriously
happening upon gorilla City so the
showrunner was like we have to find the
money we have to do gorilla City we
absolutely have to do this so they did
it and we all pooped our pants just
because it's so awesome I mean Grodd in
this episode like you can see how they
evolved his design from season one but
going to gorilla City is a step above
and beyond now the question was posed
are we going to go back to gorilla City
will there be a gorilla City episode and
this is really the whole reason for
making the video he was like well if we
did go back because it's so expensive to
do all those CG Apes all the city
escapes all that stuff it would probably
be a two-part episode just so they could
spread the cost over multiple episodes
and he talked about a few steps that
films will sometimes take to get around
cost issues like Planet of the Apes if
you guys have seen it it's all motion
capture very expensive to do the CG so
there's little tricks that they try to
pull to save money the really good
example that Andrew Kreisberg gave is
that someone on their team like on on
the inside of the flash team know
someone who worked on Planet of the Apes
and they had a bunch of physical
costumes that they made before they
decided to make the Planet of the Apes
movies CG so they had all these like
spare ape suits that looked amazing but
they just didn't end up using so the
flash people got access to that so
they're like well you know we might use
a mixture of that and then reuse the
gorilla grodd model with a bunch of
armor so you have a bunch of gorillas
that look similar to Grodd but you use
are more practical armor to make them
look different so you can kind of see
where they're going with this obviously
a two-part gorilla City episode is
probably too big to do in the back half
of season two like they've already
plotted most of the season out but to me
just the way he talked about it made it
sound like yeah we're definitely gonna
do this in a two-part episode and it's
not gonna happen this year but we'll
probably probably definitely doing it in
season three so on top of that like he
even went further beyond that he's like
if you're gonna do gorilla City well
then you have to do so levar now this is
from the showrunners mouth and the team
that brought you king sharks so they can
do things as crazy as that then you know
doing the Babe Ruth thing and calling
their shot being like well to park
realist of the episode with so levar
they're probably going to do it the
funny thing about the interview it was
actually on kevin smith's podcast is it
kevin smith you know you know regardless
of what you think about his films or
anything like that said that he felt
king shark on the flash season to look
better than doomsday did in the Batman
vs Superman trailer now Andrew Kreisberg
is the shorter of the flash he works
with Warner Brothers so he was very
political about like hey you know please
let's look at the bright side of this
you know both very awesome things going
on Kevin Smith was kind of joking around
but let me know in the comments which do
you guys think looks more badass keep in
mind they don't spend more than like two
or three million dollars per episode of
the flash and even when you think about
a 23 episode season that's still half
the budget less than half the budget of
Batman V Superman so just think about
how awesome it is that the flash people
are able to do such awesome things like
king shark gorilla grodd gorilla City in
the future that looks so good that
they're able to hold their own against
like super big-budget film effects now I
know buddy you guys are still asking
about zoom we're still wondering who he
is and it's probably gonna be a while
before we see him take his mask off but
just to explain the zoom CG like why
he's so expensive and why we don't seem
as much on-screen but the reason we
don't see him as much is a function of
the story but it also is kind of in
keeping with the theme of not trying to
blow all their money so what they do is
they use CG to stretch the mouthpiece a
little bit dark in the eyes and use the
blue lightning so the actual costume
itself probably looks a little bit
closer like this they actually haven't
released any behind-the-scenes pictures
of the zoom costume to probably wait
till after the season but you can see
like how it still requires a lot of CG
even though the suit itself is practical
in related flash matters they just
announced a couple castings one of them
was an evil speedster created by a
LuthorCorp
whenever Luthor gave a bunch of people
powers and tried to control them like he
created a bunch of super heroes whose
powers he could just turn off with a
flick
a switch I'm wondering if this speedster
character is gonna be tied to the
velocity-9 plotline that's another good
question which of the female characters
who have been speedsters in the comics
do you want to see get Speed Force
powers on the TV show first Jesse quick
iris West
patty spivot they've all had flash
powers at various points in the comics
but in case you guys didn't know the
flash is coming back January 19th arrows
coming back January 20th in legends of
tomorrow episode 1 is dropping on the
21st so it's gonna be Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday every week I'd recommend you
watch the episodes in that order Andrew
Kreisberg actually he even said that
originally legends of tomorrow was gonna
be called JSA they're like can we use
just the JSA letters without Saint
Justice and the reasoning for why they
didn't tried to call it Justice Society
is because of the expectation of
characters that you'll see that they'll
probably never be able to do Superman
being at the top of that list so it's
like if you're not gonna ever do
Superman then you can't really call it
just a society so they didn't want to
like give fans the middle finger where
it's like hey we're gonna do Galactus on
screen but he's not gonna look anything
like the Galactus that you know he's
gonna be some stupid glow cloud so
that's why it became legends of tomorrow
so that you could like be its own thing
without getting your hopes up for
characters that you never see but they
did say because it's a time-travel show
that in future seasons will probably see
other teams from earlier points in
history in the DC Universe in future
seasons that is the example that Andrew
Kreisberg gave is is that if they go
back to World War 2 era during season 1
of legends of tomorrow we're not gonna
see any other big DC heroes from that
era season 2 though is a different story
that like we probably will see team ups
from other eras as we travel to those
different time periods so that's me just
feels like they're laying seeds for
Legion of super-heroes from the future
if you're gonna travel to the future
what's the biggest team that you know
from the future the Legion and that's
another thing too if there's any
characters in present-day on arrow or
the flash that would get Legion rings
who would you want to see get the Rings
because Barry's gonna have his flash
ring he's probably not gonna wear two
rings maybe the legends of tomorrow
characters I feel like they'd probably
be the ones to get Legion rings first
but just a reminder that I'm still doing
my reverse flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll do another DC video before
the end of the week we're all announced
the winner of that I'm also doing a Star
Wars giveaway I posted
my non-spoilery review so I'll put a
link for that in the description
seriously if you haven't already be sure
to go see Star Wars this weekend I'll be
doing an Easter Egg video later I've
already done the non spoilery video you
can click here to learn all about that
don't worry no spoilers for the movie
and you can click here for all my other
flash and arrow videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight